Cuál es el ambiente que se siente en
este momento en el país
Hola hola buenas tardes noches a todos
Bueno estoy yo en Brasilia en la capital
Federal muy cerca de donde está
sucediendo todo y por aquí pasan muchos
helicópteros y algunos coches de policía
y se escucha
la movida no que que los manifestantes
han traído para la capital Federal el
clima del país desde de preocupación no
preocupación con lo que está sucediendo
y con lo que puede
pasar a suceder a partir de estos actos
no hay hay datos parecidos e invitados y
muchas ciudades de Brasil manifestantes
que tomaron manifestantes
guión terroristas como dice la prensa
nacional que tomaron las calles pidiendo
un golpe militar y pidiendo la el no
reconocimiento de las lecciones de Lula
se hay hay noticias de
manifestantes en las calles de Pablo en
Río entonces hay una preocupación de que
estos santos de Brasilia puedan fomentar
actos semejantes en otras ciudades de
Brasil no Michelle y la interrumpo para
darle la bienvenida a otro de nuestros
invitados que es callado mañanelli
consultor político y especialista en
investigación de opinión pública
política y electoral quien se encuentra
en Sao Paulo Gracias por acompañarnos
aquí en France 24 Quiero preguntarle
primero a usted y luego que Michelle
responda Por qué ocurre estos actos y ya
la policía anunció que investigarán si
bolsonaro está detrás de ellos qué tan
posible es esto
es que efectivamente bolsonaro no tiene
Lee liderazgo suficiente para decirse
como un comandante de eso pero sí
influenció durante todos sus cuatro años
este discurso de odio que es el gran
motor y motivador de este tipo de
actitud de una turba de personas que
están totalmente alienadas a lo que son
lo que es el respeto a una vida
democrática a un país institucionalizado
y todo este discurso antiestado que está
siendo proliferado por una agenda
fascista que se adapta por todo el mundo
esto de agenda fascista es un poco los
términos que ha utilizado el gobierno
izquierdista y los aliados de Lula da
Silva Le quiero preguntar a Michelle
ella está de acuerdo en que detrás de
todo esto está un poco la línea
extremista de bolsonaro y que nos
explique un poco más Cuál es la atención
entre Brasilia y el Gobierno Federal
porque aliados de Lula también estaban
diciendo que el estado fue incapaz de
proveer la seguridad necesaria y de
hecho ya la policía apenas pudo
recuperar el control en el congreso en
la Corte Suprema y en El Ejecutivo
efectivamente
[Música]
los ministerios hoy por hoy en la plaza
de los tres poderes destruyendo los
edificios públicos es gente que que ha
estado durante varias semanas
delante del cuartel del ejército no y
varias semanas incluso bajo el gobierno
bolsonaro y que no se ha desmovilizado
esta gente no eso es un punto un segundo
punto es que muchas de esas personas han
sido recibidas por bolsonaro delante de
la residencia oficial del presidente
después de las elecciones
y y no no les da reprochado la ocupación
del cuartel general entonces estoy de
acuerdo con lo que dijo Cayo antes que
que hay como una un apoyo de bolsonaro
no a a la idea de esta gente aunque no
haya que esté involucrado directamente
digamos así otro otro tema que que me ha
preguntado es el tema del gobierno del
Distrito Federal perdón y y hay que
dejar claro que el secretario de
seguridad pública del Distrito Federal
ha sido ministro del gobierno bolsonado
no y este mismo secretario pues no está
en Brasilia aunque se sepa de estas
manifestaciones Hace algunos días él el
secretario de seguridad pública del
Distrito Federal está fuera de Brasilia
y se ha noticia de que está en Estados
Unidos incluso Entonces no ha ganado la
atención necesaria para estos actos y
además la Claro está y está en las
imágenes que tenemos acceso la policía
no ha actuado con la debida fuerza
necesaria para frenar esos actos no eh A
asomado refuerzos
mucho Después de lo necesario para
efectivamente parar los manifestantes y
cuando llegaron refuerzos pues ahí
estaban ocupados El Congreso Nacional el
edificio de la suprema corte y el
palacio del plan auto donde trabaja el
presidente de la república entonces
Claro está que le van a echar esta
factura
en la cuenta
que es el gobernador del Distrito
Federal y de hecho ya destituido el
secretario de seguridad pública de su
cargo como una un acto no para disminuir
un poco la responsabilidad que tiene él
cayó ahora Quiero preguntarle a usted
que nos explique Cuáles son los alcances
legales y políticos de que el presidente
Lula haya decretado intervención Federal
Mira tenemos de dejar claro el nivel de
intervención de Federal ibanés está
pagando barato por su injerencia durante
estos dos meses que pasaron desde estas
elecciones
la manera como alineado con la seguridad
pública como no cuido de los radios
públicos que son responsabilidad del
gobierno del Instituto Federal esto todo
le salió barato primero porque la
intervención Federal solo está sobre la
seguridad pública de Brasilia no se
intervió directamente a todo el gobierno
del Distrito Federal entonces a ver
tenemos un tenemos un gobierno que sale
muy bien lo que está haciendo y el
sentido institucional si esto tuviera
pasado el gobierno anterior el
presidente bolsonaro Podría tener muy
posiblemente declarado intervención
nacional en todo espacio
lo que estamos diciendo es que Tula
decretó la intervención del Gobierno
Federal sobre la seguridad pública del
Distrito Federal que tiene Rango
autónomo de estado y está perdiendo su
autonomía solo en la carpeta de
seguridad sí Entonces yo barato la
cuenta para En ese sentido